since 2014 allies have increased defense
spending and we are moving in the right
direction
but we are not moving as fast as the
dangers world we live in demands
so while I welcome all the progress that
has been made it is obvious that we need
to do more and we need to do it faster
at our Summit and illness in July I
expect allies to agree and more
ambitious new defense investment pledge
with two percent of GDP as a minimum to
be invested in our defense
in this new and more contested world we
cannot take our security for granted
it is our security that underpins our
prosperity and our way online it shows
that seven allies now spend two percent
uh we actually expected that to be
slightly more earlier but because GDP
has increased more than expected for a
couple of allies to analyze that we
expect it to be a two percent are now
slightly below two percent
so first
uh we haven't seen any proof that China
is delivering little weapons to Russia
but we have seen some signs that this
has been a request from Russia and that
this is an issue that is is
considered
in Beijing or by the Chinese authorities
and therefore our message has been that
China should not provide lethal Aid to
to to Russia
then of course the meeting that takes
place in Moscow is part of a pattern we
have seen over the last years where
China and Russia are coming closer and
closer we have to remember that just a
couple of weeks or a few weeks before
the invasion last February president XI
and President Putin met in Beijing where
they signed a joint declaration
promising each other a partnership
without any limits and and we see how
China and Russia are coming closer and
closer in the military domain the joint
exercises joint patrols Naval and air
Patrols in the economic domain and also
in the political and diplomatic domain
so the meeting in Moscow is part of that
pattern where China and Russia are
working more and more closely and
building a stronger and stronger
partnership